[Music]
hello again time then for the Press
preview it's our first look at the front
pages of tomorrow's papers and we'll be
looking at the headlines tonight with
the pr consultant Alex Dean and the
broadcaster and former government
Minister Anna subri they'll both be with
us from now until just before midnight a
very good evening to you too we'll chat
in a moment after we've had a look at
some of those front pages for you
beginning with the eye leading with the
poll suggesting that 80 of people think
the government is failing to tackle the
energy crisis the first issue Liz truss
will face assuming she becomes prime
minister of course but the telegraph
says that Liz truss has a plan to tackle
energy bills ready to go on day one of
her Premiership if she steps over the
threshold of Number 10. the Ft however
has been doing its sums and says Liz
trusses tax and spending plans if she
comes to office would leave a 60 billion
pound hole in the public finances
the express predicts that the new prime
minister will call a general election
perhaps as early as October next year
the star predicts the cost of energy
will ruin Christmas as councils won't be
able to afford to switch on their
festive lights
Liz truss comes under attack from a
senior police chief in the guardian over
her plans to reform policing they're
labeled as meaningless and unwise
well the times reports that Russia has
delayed reopening its gas pipeline to
Europe following a maintenance break
after G7 countries had slapped a price
cap on Russian oil sales to try to limit
Putin's funding for the war in Ukraine
the male says that pressure is mounting
on MPS to drop the Parliamentary inquiry
into party gates after a top QC called
it unfair and flawed
while the mirror leads with news that
the queen has been forced to miss her
favorite Highland Games even while at
Balmoral because of her continuing
Mobility problems
and finally the sun leads with news that
a chain of restaurants famed for its
waitresses in skimpy costumes is to
sponsor and under 10 football team in
Nottinghamshire
and please remember that you can just
scan the QR code you can see on screen
during the program check out the front
pages while you watch us discussing them
and to discuss them PR consultant Alex
Dean and the broadcast reformer
government Minister Anna subri really
nice to have you both with us uh this
Friday evening what a few weeks it's
been Anna but we'll soon be out of our
Agony won't we we are going to get a new
Tory leader new prime minister uh we'll
hear it's going to be on Monday they'll
go into number 10 on Tuesday
yeah and you know there will be a lot of
people who will say thank goodness now
that it's all over because it's dragged
on and of course as it's dragged on
um we are spot this crisis is spiraling
and the eye quite rightly points out
that then it says it's an incredible
poll that the eyes conducted that has
found that 80
of Voters say that they're they're
pretty cheesed off with this government
because it doesn't have a plan and it
doesn't have a plan and it should have
had a plan
um and it should have had that plan and
been put into place long before now
given um the way that energy prices have
rocked it there's another stat in this
poll which I thought was very
interesting and extremely concerning
which is 86 of people that were polled
said that they would be spending less
money I mean this is obvious but that
they would be spending less money on the
High Street so yet again another
terrible squeeze on our high street
they're going to be squeezed because of
the rising Energy prices there's no cap
for small businesses and on top of that
obviously because all of us are going to
have so much less money to spend we
won't be spending on the High Street I
mean we really are going into the most
desperately concerning of times I I
honestly think it's going to be the
worst certainly in my lifetime yeah it's
all uh extremely worrying uh which is
why the Daily Telegraph has the headline
Alex energy plan on day one for trust uh
well you'd Sort of hope so wouldn't you
yes and um the piece of course doesn't
go into much detail because we don't
know what the plan is yet but
um it's a relief of course to know that
our presumptive prime minister will be
announcing something as soon as she
takes office Anna and I can at least
agree on the relief factor it's I don't
think the conservative party will ever
fight a leadership contest like the one
we've just had ever again I don't think
the kind of Gap that you have between
the members of parliament narrowing down
to two and that length of time before
the members choose is conducive to
anything positive now of course there is
an argument that members should have an
opportunity to you know see the
candidates and weigh up their merits but
for it to go on this long I mean 12. 12
hostings in the end Alex something it
did go on foreign of course the majority
I mean something like half of all
members voted by return of post so
people informed views already
um these are two veteran politicians
who've been in the front line for some
time certainly lose trust is one of the
longest serving cabinet Ministers of the
24 first century you know you didn't
need to know much more about about her
and Richie sunac was the past Chancellor
of the exchecker for goodness sake so we
knew a good deal about those candidates
already and even if you do think you
know it's right for the candidates to be
vetted I don't think any more will ever
have a contest that kind of of length
again on the other point that you have
both been discussing about
um what comes next of course Liz truss's
answer is we need to have some tax cuts
so that we can try and stimulate
economic activity stimulate growth and
in the end that'll mean more of a return
to the exchequer that is contrary to
what some people have said that is a
conservative perspective it's kind of
Ronald Reagan perspective rather than a
balance the books perspective not
everybody agrees with it but it's
certainly something that I think
deserves to be debated and I think that
if people are really thinking about
cutting back significantly on their
discretionary spending putting some
money back in their pockets is not a bad
idea yeah well wish you soon I could
cause famously said it was a fairy tale
economic plan the front of the uh ft
Anna says it's going to put 60 billion
pound budget hole in the country's
finances
there you are and there is the reality
of uh this fanciful nonsense that are
being put forward by Liz trust and it's
from the conservative party it's
extraordinary I mean you could always in
the past trust the conservatives with
the economy and on this basis you
absolutely can't uh and the the Ft quite
properly
is is exposing these nonsenses and flaws
just very quickly on this idea of tax
cuts I mean if you don't have 40 of
people in this country don't pay income
tax and the idea that if you cut taxes
somehow that is going to alleviate the
hundreds the thousands of extra pounds
that people are going to be paying for
their energy bills is for the birds I
mean you can't say that oh this is
conservative policy conservative policy
for Generations has been this one nation
Theory exposed many years ago obviously
by the Israeli that was all about
helping everybody and it was the
absolute duty of those that have to help
those that do not have and tax cuts will
not achieve that we are in extraordinary
times and we need a we need proper cool
heads doing responsible things with our
economy and you won't get that with Liz
trust as the ft is pointing out
irresponsible Alex
yeah it's a shame to hear Anna talking
about the party to which she used to
belong like that not least because there
is a perfectly respectable economic set
of thinking that says that you can
stimulate economic activity by reducing
the amount of tax the state takes I do
accept it doesn't address the energy
issue and that's why government also
needs to reduce very significantly the
amount of levies and duties that are
placed upon energy bills and fuel at
least in the short term it will run up
against some some proper and reasonable
arguments about Net Zero and green
Targets in the future but right now if
people are debating with themselves
about whether they can afford to heat
their homes or on the other hand the
extraordinary prices they're paying at
the petrol pumps it's right for
government to take off those prices that
which government itself puts on it and
you can do that at the same time as
trying to remove people's burdens from
uh income tax and the like it's not
mutually exclusive in the end we've got
to make energy cheaper in this country
for consumers in the short term because
it's a this is a real crisis and that's
quite separate to the discussion about
what happens with inflation and what
happens with the High Street which you
can also address and I think it's best
to approach these things without an
attitude of complete and utter cynicism
when you think about them
well you know the thing about tax cuts
which we already know is that it there's
a real danger that they will actually
increase inflation that is the real
danger in the situation especially that
we are in and Alex I would gently say
this to you you know when you've got
former members of the conservative party
the form of conservative MPS members of
the conservative government with these
views I am I am not alone and the
conservative party should be really
worried about what is happening in the
country people are turning away from the
Tory body looking on at this contest and
these fanciful ideas with apps there are
appalled Alex okay well
you left the Tory party you stood as
independent you got thrashed and Boris
Johnson got an 80 seat majority you
tested that too with the public and they
don't agree with you okay
listen while we're talking about
elections I just want to we're in the
different sets of situations now
colleagues from where we were in 2019.
okay let's just squeeze in the front
sorry to interrupt let's just squeeze in
the front of the uh Daily Express then
because it's sort of related before we
go to the break uh the tour is put on
wall footing for a snap election it
could happen uh October the 5th next
year Anna Tory members it seems uh want
Liz trust to be prime minister but what
about the electorate what about those
who voted Tori last time um are they are
they going to want her
I was like well I've just said I mean I
really do think the conservative party
is in is in a a dreadful situation I
think people are as I've said fed up at
the spectacle of the of this contest and
of course some of the the most Savage
attacks on the conservative government
aren't from ex-conservative MPS like me
but by by Richie sunak and Liz trust
themselves trashing 12 years of
conservative government saying things
have got to change quite extraordinary
and I think it is again for the birds to
think that there'll be a general
election next October look nobody being
you know being trying to be unpartisan
about this nobody would want to be prime
minister coming in to this huge economic
crisis it would be tough for anybody the
idea that by next October some how
things will be better they'll be
considerably worse and the blame will
rightly be laid at the door of number
ten the way I'd be very surprised if
there was a general election okay we're
going to go to break Alex we'll get your
thoughts on a general election a little
bit later on don't worry about that
coming up we're gonna have plenty more
in the Press preview including the
mirrors front page which reads that the
queen has a new health flow talk about
that and more very shortly
[Music]
hello again parts of the press preview
uh Anna and Alex are still with me Alex
front page of the mirror uh the queen
pulling out of the Braemar Gathering
it's something that she loves dearly uh
goes every year you sort of can expect
her and forgive her for pulling out of
the stuff that is perhaps a bit boring
and a bit tedious but the stuff that she
actually really enjoys when she pulls
out of that well is it is it is it cause
for concern Alex
I think so look she can pull out of
whatever event she likes a lifetime of
Public Service you can attend or not
attend I think uh now as she wishes but
I mean it's a bad sign plainly she loves
this event
um it's not as you uh rightly imply like
she's um is passing some duties that she
wouldn't have looked forward to uh it's
a sign like the new prime minister
having to go to Scotland rather than
being uh received being received by the
queen in London it's the first time in
over 100 years that has happened it's
obviously sub-optimal and we wish our
Queen a happy and long life um but it's
obviously not good that she's dropping
out of commitments like this Anna
yeah I agree I mean the Braemar
Gathering
um is not that far from Balmoral and
it's right the queen does enjoy it
um well she certainly gives the
impression that she enjoys it I'm sure
she does actually and it's quite a
feature of her thought late summer
autumn stay up at Balmoral and so I
think this is again I just think this I
agree completely without I think this is
very very disturbing because you know
she's such a huge part isn't she of our
of our lives and our our own history
um and she's 96 and it just worries I
think he just worries us all that she's
so poorly she can't go to the Highland
gathering at Brama yeah of course uh
well we wish her well and let's hope
things uh things uh go well on Tuesday
let's move on to the front of the times
Alex uh so the G7 fireman Finance
ministers agreed to put a price cap on
oil from Russia uh to try and reduce uh
moscow's revenues and then a few hours
later that this oil leak appears on the
North stream one pipeline coincidence
what a terrible coincidence just in the
same way that Nordstrom one's been under
maintenance since uh the dispute that
led to the effective cessation of
Nordstrom 2. the thing about the G7 step
which of course in on principle many of
us will look at and applaud is that it
assumes that it's a world basic embargo
or a world price capital and of course
it isn't we talk in the media as if
we've cut Russia off from the global
economy and we haven't we've cut Russia
off from the Western global economy
there are plenty of countries that will
do business with Russia still India and
China to name but two have remained
scrupulously neutral with regard to
Russia's illegal uh and aggressive
invasion of the Ukraine India has moved
from being a pretty
um minor importee of Russian energy
especially coal to being a massive uh
importer of of Russian coal and you do
think to yourself well if we say we're
only going to pay so much somebody else
may pay more all right I mean in the
it's probably a good thing that we pivot
away from dependence on Russia per se
anyway it's probably a good thing that
we skip straight to the conclusion the
last chapter being Nordstrom one being
turned off it will mean some very
unattractive and unhappy moments for our
friends in Germany who are dependent on
Russia for plus 50 of their gas but I
think in the long term it's good that we
get off that um restriction but in the
immediate term it's going to be
uncomfortable and you better bet in the
end the Russians will sell it to
somebody else yeah and just a very quick
thought on this
no I I agree with that now and actually
really don't have anything to add to it
except that again it just adds to the
Grave concerns that so many of us have
about the energy crisis Rising bills and
just the overall economic situation here
and obviously overseas yeah and of
course as these sanctions continue
um uh we continue to suffer here as well
don't we um Anna Alex thank you both
very much